[Music]
foreign
[Music]
to the reason Roundtable your weekly
libertarian podcast from the magazine
that's doing better this morning than
Yankee fans I am Matt Welch joined by
Nick lesb Peter suterman and pinch
hitting for gimpy Catherine Menge Ward
none other than Fiona Harrigan good
morning Pals
hello
hey Matt
happy Monday there you go Peter's been
working on this pronunciation of rushi
Rishi sunak right I've already either
that or he is he is really on some kind
of supersed it
this you know it's not uh it's not
either or never is
um the UK UK has a prime a new prime
minister as badly uh mentioned already
we'll talk about that a little later in
the proceedings but first let's get to
what everybody on this side of the pond
is yammering about
and that's the upcoming midterm
elections by everybody I do mean actor
director Rob Reiner who on Sunday
tweeted in the next 16 days Americans
will decide if we want to remain a
constitutional democracy or live under
fascism I have voted for democracy if
you agree vote blue
uh meat head aside there's just a ton of
apocalyptic rhetoric going around in the
media right now historian and MSNBC
regular Jason Stanley this very morning
we'd do this on Monday tweeted what is
your plan now that American democracy is
likely a thing of History will you tell
your kids about what it was like will
you lie to them about what it is now
uh it's pretty easy to make fun of all
the hysterics it's a bit harder for
everyone whether they be doomsayers or
Skeptics thereof to spell out concretely
what it would mean if the GOP does with
the opposition party to the president so
often does two years after he's elected
and that is retake control of the house
and maybe even the Senate Peter you live
in DC in your weird little Lair there
with a 9 000 pound dog behind you uh you
always dress up as Mitch McConnell for
Halloween can you give us a preliminary
sense of whether Republicans indeed plan
to tank the global economy
uh in order to force uh social security
cuts as I keep reading about in the
pages of New York Magazine in the
Washington Post
my God they're animals
yeah probably yeah yeah is that your
sense look so the
the Articles you keep reading are
articles written uh from a sort of
left-wingish pro-democrat uh you know
pro-democratic party perspective that
are they're looking for a hook that will
help the that will help Democrats in the
midterm and the hook they have settled
on and I actually think there's you know
some uh reason to think that this is an
effective political message is that if
Republicans win back the house and the
Senate they will use the upcoming debt
limit uh expiration to uh to basically
hold to they will hold the debt limit
hostage
um in or and their demand will be well
we have to cut Medicare and Social
Security Republicans have this is
there's some reason to think that like
some version of that is true because a
bunch of Republicans have said look
there's a debt limit uh expiration date
coming up
and when that happens uh probably uh
what we're gonna do is we're going to
say hey look Social Security and
Medicare have kind of shaky finances
maybe we should work on reforming them
um and so they were they're not putting
forward specific proposals right now but
there are have been a couple of
proposals from the past couple of years
and they include things like hey maybe
we should means test entitlements so
let's not give entitlements to seniors
who are really well off or maybe we
should raise the raise the age of uh
retirement so that uh so that people
don't get Medicare or Social Security
immediately at 65 like 10 years from now
that's the the kind of thing that
they're talking about and that's what
that the sort of the the left-wing
industrial political complex right now
wants you to be afraid of and look
there's there's you know like I said as
a political message this may well be
somewhat effective because Medicare and
Social Security are in fact quite
popular and if you can portray a party
as trying to cut them as trying to cut
those programs then that's typically a
winning political message that's why
Donald Trump spent four years saying I'm
absolutely not going to touch Medicare
and Social Security because he
understands that they are popular
programs which is a detail that seems to
go absent in some of these analyzes
about what the Republicans remember
those other times when the Republicans
controlled everything I mean they burned
it to the ground I mean every time the
Democrats manage to get back into office
so you know their their questions to
rebuild these programs absolutely
questions about how serious any of this
is and what Republicans are going to do
the Republican party is a total clown
show at this at the moment they do not
you know this is not like they have like
really rallied around a bunch of
specific plans here uh but it's I I do
think that it's at least possible that
something like this will happen but so
on the policy merits this is what's not
getting talked about here is we could
argue about whether the debt limit is
the best vehicle for uh for negotiating
reforms to Social Security and Medicare
but if nothing happens if Congress
doesn't do something Social Security and
Medicare are going to cut themselves and
they're going to do so in a radical and
dramatic way not a like a planned way
which is what the Republican plans to
the extent that they exist have
suggested it's not talk they're not you
know the met when medicare's uh Hospital
Insurance trust fund uh goes um becomes
insolvent in 2027 or so what happens is
that immediately Medicare cannot pay all
of its bills overnight when Social
Securities trust fund becomes insolvent
in the 2030s what happens is that
immediately Social Security cannot pay
out all of its checks overnight and so
what if Republicans go ahead with this
again I'm not sure I I think that the
debt limit is the best vehicle for for
doing this kind of negotiation but if
Republicans go ahead with us then but
why why we why are we why are we acting
there is no reason to believe that
they're going to do this I mean this is
a political strategy by the Democrats
who Peter is right that the Republicans
you know is a clown show that is
literally headed by a guy who recently
said he would throw you know various
kinds of whistleblowers in jail so they
would be raped I mean that's Donald
Trump in his most recent public Persona
you know to to the the cheers of
thousands in the audience that's where
the Republican party is and the running
people like Herschel Walker who is you
know who who is still bringing down the
nape scores for fourth grade reading for
God's sake I mean it's a terrible party
that is about to win big in the house
because the Democratic party is headed
by a guy who is talking to people who
died years ago and you know and and has
just pumped trillions of dollars into
the economy and has led a disastrous two
years so you know I don't know if like
if we want to talk about political you
know uh uh you know strategies and stuff
like that but there's no reason to fear
a midterm Republican win in the house
and possibly the Senate which is looking
more likely but it's still kind of iffy
that is not the end of democracy that is
the next click in the wheel of democracy
and the real problem from a Libertarian
point of view is you know that neither
of these parties is it all serious and
there's a really deep question about
whether or not the libertarian party is
actually to follow up I mean should we
not be concerned that we're about to see
a restoration of power uh in a party
where 147 members of Congress didn't
vote to certify the presidential
election and where you have uh you know
gubernatorial candidates in Arizona and
Michigan and Pennsylvania yeah it's
trouble um is it possible that all the
boys crying wolf out there are
distracting us from an act actual wolf
and should we be concerned about big
things with fangs at the door
I am not worried about anything uh any
emanations of or you know proclamations
of looming fascism from uh Jason Stanley
or Rob Ryder uh that is ridiculous it's
hyperbolic and it is incendiary at a at
a particular time when what we actually
need to be doing is sifting through
candidates who are not insane from
either party and putting them in one
Camp because you know we also have
people she's going to lose big in
Georgia but you know Stacy Abrams who
was talking about how like you know
really the the tight connection now is
between inflation and having kids uh you
know and that's why we need better
abortion because you know kids are going
to inflate the economy or something like
that the level of political rhetoric is
so [ __ ] stupid
um you know that's got to be the primary
focus unless you are in the tank for the
Republican or Democratic party I I
welcome for sure a house win or or the
Republicans taking over the house
because it will act as a check on a
Congress that has been terrible so far
and that doesn't say anything good about
Donald Trump or anything and it's not
nihilistic it's like right now we need a
check on the way that the government has
been uh you know has been spending money
under Joe Biden and I think that will
happen uh what happens next who knows uh
you know because Bill Clinton I I think
a lot back in Matt I know to you and to
me this does not seem like ancient
history it doesn't even really seem like
you know it's it's like a couple weeks
ago but Bill Clinton who uh unlike Joe
Biden got in with the lowest winning
percentage since uh Richard Nixon he won
with like 43 percent of the vote in 1992
looked like he was going to be a
one-termer who would not even you know
get a parking lot concession in James
Buchanan's uh Presidential Library it
was such a failure the Republicans blew
him out in 1994 and then he ended up
being one of the most successful
presidents of our lifetime time because
whatever mix of effluvium that was
coming out of Newt Gingrich and Bill
Clinton and seeping out of every Fabric
in Washington DC in that period you know
ended up concocting a brew that was
pretty successful from a from an
economic and political standpoint so who
knows but no democracy is not threatened
if the Republicans win the house Nick
are you not at least a little bit
worried Jason Stanley aside uh Rob
Reiner aside about someone like Carrie
Lake winning the governor's race in uh
you know yeah and like installing in
Arizona and installing people into
positions of power over elections in
like a potential swing state yeah uh
yeah sure
and is that the end of democracy I don't
think so I mean we heard those stories
about Georgia and you know Brian Kemp
was like a monster right who's about to
become the governor of Georgia so yeah
there's lots of things a guy who was
there's a lot of resisted Trump's yeah I
know but he was by the by democrats at
the time he was we were being told that
he was in the tank and that he was you
know rounding up mailboxes and things
like that yeah of course the All-Star
Game in in Georgia come on uh Carey lake
is a disturbing Apparition and you know
it is it is frightening I mean on some
level uh it's also Arizona which is you
know is now officially kind of a purple
state so we'll see it always from from
it's Inception but in any case no I
don't I think yes I don't think the the
point is that these abnormalities aside
this is not a threat to the Republic and
people who reach for that are not
serious thinkers including people at
Catherine's Alma Motors Fiona you were
negative five years old uh in 1994 or
they're about absolutely
86. uh let's get you in on on a subject
that you've been talking uh and writing
about a lot which is Ukraine there's
been a bunch of contradictory reporting
about what a republican uh majority
would mean for U.S support for Ukraine
versus Russia what's your latest sense
of where that stands yeah you know
funding for Ukraine is a super hot
button issue and a lot of uh Republican
leaders and politicians seem to suggest
that a republican-led Congress would
handle that more surely than the
Democrats have and they've definitely
been the loudest voices calling for
things like accountability oversight
certain mechanisms for restraint and
making sure that you know weapons and
Aid end up in the right hands
essentially
um but it's it's kind of in the way that
a lot of Democrats have faltered on
immigration there's spend this
convergence around you know sending
these massive Aid packages that some
otherwise fiscally conservative
Republicans would otherwise oppose right
they've been very happy to be very
spendy and some areas that are perhaps
ill-advised and and perhaps uh have been
predicted by previous conflicts like
Afghanistan you know we've seen very
strong examples of Aid and weapons
ending up in the wrong hands if we flood
them into quickly and if we don't think
about these things up front
um you know and I think a lot of
Libertarians might disagree on the
wisdom of funding for Ukraine it's seen
as a good alternative in some ways to
boots on the ground and direct
assistance their soldiers but with the
us out spending basically all of Europe
for a conflict much closer to their
backyard it's kind of hard to see those
priorities as fiscally responsible and a
lot of Republicans have voted and sided
with the Democrats in favor of Aid to
Ukraine so absent oversight in a devoted
Inspector General which has been floated
by folks like Rand Paul things like that
I I expect there's going to be some
incoming hesitance among Republicans
there's been a trend upward in the
number of Republicans who have voted
against Aid now that the initial shock
of the Russian invasion is wearing off
but it's hard to imagine that there
would be transformative changes
especially as both parties seem overly
willing to spend American money without
much debate
Peter there's uh you've mentioned in the
past
um something along the lines that
Personnel is policy
um uh might even sort of amend that of
saying the the personality of people in
positions of power uh uh sometimes
matter uh uh pretty heavily as well um
this is just a way of segwaying into
Mitch McConnell who you followed for a
long time versus Kevin McCarthy Mitch
McConnell if Republicans take the Senate
um uh it's going to be a lot of
McConnell a lot of McCarthy
um everything I have seen and heard
about Kevin McCarthy in the history of
his entire life is that he is a stupid
person just like a dumb person
um Mitch McConnell uh uh whatever one
says about uh his wisdom his heart his
lizard brain
um he's stupid is usually not what comes
out Mitch McConnell would run Washington
or run a congress effectively uh if
Republicans take both uh Chambers am I
correcting that I think that's an open
question I McCarthy would have more
power than he's ever had before and
that I think there there would be no
escaping to some extent that that he
would be able to make calls in a way
that he has not been able to make before
uh yeah I agree with your assessment
there I mean Mitch McConnell whatever
else you think of him is just tactically
very Savvy I think that's often to the
detriment of American politics uh Mitch
McConnell has always had exactly one
goal which is to elect Republicans and
then not really have them do anything in
hopes of making sure that elect that
Republicans are elected as often as
possible hence the the thing that he has
cared about most that's sort of um
that's like sort of outside that is is
that uh is is the corpse right and so he
has like really moved a lot of uh uh
Republican appointees into the courts
but that's at least in part because he
sees the courts as a better vehicle for
making decisions than Congress and he
doesn't want Republicans to have to have
their names on stuff because he just
wants elect Republicans insert service
of it's just never actually been clear
what McCarthy is is not tactically or
strategically Savvy and it's also not
clear exactly what he stands for on
policy but it's totally plausible that
he could end up
adopting some sort of policy platform
position of the moment but my guess is
that that a McCarthy rain would end up
not so much being about policy instead
it would be about really dumb political
attacks on Joe Biden and just hearing
after hearing on stuff like Hunter Biden
and God knows what like kind of dumb
scandals like they have the Republican
party has already signaled that if they
get power with Biden still in office
that's what they're going to use it for
and that seems like the kind of thing
that McCarthy is really going to be
motivated by Freedom caucus for the win
Freedom means investigating Hunter
Biden's laptop I'm looking forward to a
final uh you know uh wrap-up of Benghazi
and if they can you know somehow get
Hunter Biden tied to Benghazi Matt then
uh it's not the end of democracy it's
the beginning finally get the uh
McCarthy
well I was going to say McCarthy if I'm
not mistaken is the last of the Young
Guns who is still in office
yeah no even Emilio Estevez is like no I
had nothing to do with that yeah Kevin
McCarthy is the Lou Diamond Phillips of
uh Congress it or the Casey sesh Mako uh
it is he is so he so typifies the
mediocrity that people like H.L Menken
struggle to find you know the words to
put into uh onto the page he's terrible
and like Peter said he will be awful
like in what Mitch McConnell will be
awful because he doesn't want to do
anything other than shovel money to his
pet interests and things like that which
is bad enough uh and Mitch McConnell
will be in some ring of Hell uh you know
that has not yet been discovered but
Kevin McCarthy is stupid and will do bad
things that not only hurt the future
Republican party which I could give two
shits about but he will do things that
will make the next two years even more
miserable than it's already a fun fact
about Young Guns the uh the uh what the
Western in the late 80s with all these
the the new Brat Pack
um uh when uh I was a a a a a child in
Long Beach teenager we used to drive up
to Westwood and like to walk around oh
that was exciting a thing to do in high
school and we stumbled upon the movie
premiere of Young Guns like a red carpet
and all the various uh Stars walking
there and it was the first time I were
you bitten by a radioactive it was the
first time that I was made aware of the
Hollywood cliche that all actors with
like two exceptions are just
horrifically short all these guys were
little Hobbits walking through and
they're like wow we could take those
guys in basketball totally all right uh
one of the major themes that Republicans
have been hammering on uh during this
election is immigration I cannot tell
you uh how many thousands of times I
have seen this was it citizens for
sanity TV commercial during the baseball
playoffs about how like every single
Democrat Pratt has voted to allow
illegal immigrants to stab people in Las
Vegas I think that's the the direct
quote uh Fiona you follow this issue
pretty closely the politics and the
issue of it how much does
no I thought we were going to talk about
that no
um you I'm sure you will find a way to I
thought we were going to talk about
Emilio asked to inject it into I like
how when I say Fiona immediately the
dudes start talking
can you give us a sense of how much the
immigration is looming as an issue what
the comparative party messaging is on it
and whether any of it Bears any
resemblance to reality of what
immigration policy at the chaotic
seeming border is right now yeah sure
you know I've been in Arizona for about
a week now and it's really astonishing
how many times one campaign ad can say
the words fentanyl open borders and gang
members that's that's about the tenor
down here uh you know and it's a central
plank for Republican candidates these
days people like Blake Masters and Care
Lake over here but even in law uh you
know in races that are very far away
from the border and it's kind of a first
cousin to Law and Order the
crime-focused messaging that a lot of
candidates are pulling but actual
immigration reform is basically
Untouchable in Congress and I think
there are a couple reasons for that uh
one is that uh you know in a way a lot
of Democrats have capitulated two
Republican messaging so here in Arizona
there are some Senators uh Kirsten
Cinema and Mark Kelly who have moved to
delay the end of title 42 which is a
pandemic error policy that Biden has
continued after the Trump Administration
imposed it which allows border officials
to expel Asylum Seekers so that sort of
thing is is kind of you know in this in
candy Valley of Republicans meeting
Democrats in Arizona
and a lot of those politicians mentioned
the same thing right that the policies
that the Biden Administration has kept
in place are creating chaos at the U.S
Mexico border
um whether that's true or not really
depends on who you ask and what data you
parse but a lot of Republicans have said
that they won't consider things like
Visa reforms and measures to bring in
phds and stem workers until the border
is secure but what they don't mention is
how destabilizing a lot of the Trump
Administration policies were at the
border and how a lot of the build up of
that is now manifesting down here at the
U.S Mexico border so for example title
42 it's really reduced legal Pathways
things like Asylum Trump also really
drastically reduced Refugee Admissions
and work visas legal immigration which
has essentially forced migrants who are
determined to migrate to migrate
illegally so with Asylum no longer
really a thing during the pandemic a lot
of people were crossing illegally
because they had no other option really
there were pre-pandemic expulsions for
migrants that would carry penalties so
you know people really didn't attempt
repeat Crossings if they were caught for
fear of punishment but title 482 doesn't
penalize in the same way which means
that repeat Crossings are super high
down here which means that there's
really inflated data in terms of
Crossings and apprehensions so that's
something that a lot of Republicans miss
out on and a lot of Democrats who are
now siding with Republicans Miss but
policy changes that would actually help
mitigate that you know restoring Asylum
at the ports is really really important
and the Biden Administration restored
Asylum for Haitians and essentially
completely shifted ninety percent of
Haitian migrants Crossing illegally to
90 over 90 Crossing legally things like
increasing work visa delegation those
things are very highly correlated to
reductions in illegal migration but all
of that is essentially Untouchable
because everybody just goes ape [ __ ]
over the border and nobody can actually
talk reasonably about these reforms to
the point where there's only one major
piece of legislation that I know of the
farm Workforce modernization act that
Republicans are co-sponsoring in pretty
large numbers comparatively uh that is
actually geared toward immigration
reform so this is this is essentially an
Untouchable issue now
Peter I read Uh Kevin McCarthy's a
commitment to America so that you didn't
have to
um it also it takes about as long to
finish as My Pet Goat I think uh here is
the complete did you read that on a menu
tray at like a norm it was on a it was
on the back of my fortune at the Chinese
restaurant here's the uh complete and
total plan uh to regain control of the
Southern border you ready
Peter uh
um is your body I'm not body ready could
I possibly be ready fully fund effective
border enforcement strategies
infrastructure and advanced technology
yes to prevent illegal Crossings and
trafficking by cartels
and catch and release loopholes
require proof of legal status to get a
job
and eliminate welfare incentives so that
ought to do it right
I like that he's leaving open that space
for artisanal traffickers
you know not the cartels come on they're
big business they don't care about the
people they're you know taking advantage
of
fully fund effective strategies
who could be against that it's a Madman
crazy maybe I'm surprised they didn't
like uh want to crack down and waste
Fraud and Abuse I I think that's the so
the stressian reading is they won't fund
anything because none of the strategies
are effective
wouldn't it be great if like you know uh
uh uh there's a new a season of Surreal
Life coming out but like if Dr Drew just
expanded Sober House to cover Congress
and it was like 535 people you know
living in a Dr Drew Pinsky sober house
and then um I don't know I think that
would be preferable to what is going to
come just as long as John Boehner could
wobble into the picture now and then
again oh yeah he would be leading every
other meeting come on this ends with a
bunch of Republican Governors
nationalizing uh like Greyhound right
and then just just bussing every
immigrant directly to New York DC and
Martha's Vineyard yeah but where Eric
Adams can't be found because he's out at
some kind of a late night uh secret club
that wearing really cool clothes and
then they're going to argue that this is
that this is actually fiscally
conservative because Greyhound was
operating at a loss or something right
if you like if you have the Amtrak guys
take over Greyhound it'll somehow or
another will save money on the trips
that if every immigrant if every illegal
immigrant is carrying at least two
Amazon packages it all balances out
they're all going to end up rebalancing
the city bike so what happened finally
finally all those City bikes that are
downtown will be driven Uptown you know
no I mean it this is a good question
because so far the Republican
immigration policy has been uh to use
immigrants as props and political stunts
there has not been any sort of serious
effort to to put forward something that
is stable functional right that it could
like that can actually last and is going
to work at the border because
Republicans don't have that plan what
they have is a bunch of gripes that
they're going to love but Democrats uh
because they think that it will help
them win elections but then if they if
and when they end up in power with uh
you know actually having responsibility
over this it's totally unclear what
they'll they will do because they don't
know because their their position is we
should fully fund effective strategies
good luck with that guys
it's also true that the Democrats have
failed at anything approaching
immigration reform or even immigration
control and you know to a certain degree
Trump was the beneficiary of uh you know
part of his his extremeness at the
border did discourage people uh but it's
also that the conditions in the sending
countries also have changed and that
that's one of the things I think from a
specifically libertarian perspective
that is it it exceeds even the grasp of
most Libertarians which is that the
receiving country is not the you know is
not the dictator of flows in the way
that we might think and it's really
governments don't control borders
effectively anymore except in absolute
authoritarian countries uh any more that
they control the economy and things like
that and they can hold the line for a
little bit but things come back and what
we desperately need in America and
Americans are ready for this politicians
are not as the have that just discussion
about why more immigration is better
than less immigration and more legal
immigration
is better than less legal immigration we
have a population problem in this
country which is that we don't have
enough people to do the work that is
already available plus the work that
will grow if we have more people it's
really disastrous and this uh I don't
know how much it will actually affect
directly this election because
everything is really hinging on the
economy and I think historically
immigration is kind of a proxy for
economic issues as well as issues about
things like drugs or sinisterness
immigrants and drugs have always been
linked in the popular imagination for
political outcomes but also with the
pandemic immigrants and sickness and
illness have always been linked so this
is lurking but I think it is a secondary
issue to the main driver of what's going
on in this election which is an economy
that everybody knows is shitty and it's
almost certainly going to get worse
because of the way the government has
been acting over the past
four you know eight six definitely this
was supposed to be one of Kamala
Harris's jobs early on was fixing the
root causes of migration in Central
America and she went on this awful media
tour down there and essentially the
conclusion was that we should just pay
these countries to keep their people at
home which is a total misread of
government power and Corruption down
there but also begs the question of
fiscal responsibility when we have how
many jobs open 11 million jobs that God
knows how many immigrants could fill and
happily would
all right we're going to get to our
listener email of the week here in a
moment but first
is it from an immigrant Matt no well
actually I'm not sure that's a good
question I might even be from an uh a
non-uh resident uh we'll see uh I don't
think we asked that question on the
email submission it's true but we do ask
if they're felons right because we
prioritize felons in the questions it
has to be written with a a prison uh uh
return address
um but first I'm going to read an ad
people if you stop talking we're all
except for nicholaspi responsible adults
here we do what it takes to ensure our
families in case of a medical emergency
but what many of us don't realize is
that health insurance won't always cover
the full cost of an emergency medical
flight
even comprehensive coverage can leave
you with high deductibles and co-pays
that is where air Med Care Network comes
in when you sign up to become a member
of airmed Care Network should any such
emergency arise you will not see a bill
for air Medical Transport when flown by
an amcn provider airmed care flying
machines transport more than 100 000
patients each year best of all this
peace of mind for your whole family can
be yours beginning at the low low price
of 85 a year listeners to the round
table can get gift cards to their new
memberships for up to fifty dollars
through either Visa or Amazon simply
visit airmedcarnetwork.com reason and
use the offer code reason start
protecting your family do it today
you'll be glad you did all right
reminder email your succincts queries to
Roundtable at reason.com this one comes
from Larkin Hogle
Larkin Hogle is the name it's a
fantastic name you think it's real Nick
Larkin Hogle yeah it's got to be real
It's gotta be all right no nobody it's
like remember like when you're reading
those little uh uh like uh novels for
kids they would always have the the most
Preposterous novels for kids uh what are
you talking crazy about what they'd
always have like crazy names like uh
yeah Jackrabbit you know anyways Rupert
McDowell rimple and stuff like that
sorry Larkin Hogle uh this was said to
us before the announcement of the new uh
Tory prime minister by the way uh hogo
writes uh please see the follow uh
following comment from British
conservative party MP Robert halffon and
now I'm quoting from that the government
has looked like libertarian jihadists
and treated the whole country as kind of
laboratory mice on which to carry out
Ultra Ultra free market experiments
he told Sky News that's a conservative
party MP
um and here comes the question from
Larkin hogel uh how can we prevent
Libertarians from being slandered as
such if as the UK markets suggested
meaning the financial markets Freer
Economic Policy requires short-term
suffering to achieve longer-term gains
do Americans have the stomach required
to approach such policies Nick I would
invite you to answer that question
looking through the American lens feels
like we're miles and miles away from
anything that might be a branded
austerity how would those politics go
down in 2022
yeah I I don't know
sorry
um I I was bedazzled by the vision of a
Libertarian jihadist who somehow like
you know asks for permission to come
into your house and then sits down and
says you know like can I talk to you
about libertarianism and then when you
say get the [ __ ] out they just leave
this is
you know that's a Libertarian job Peter
you somebody who's very polite and
respectful all right uh Peter you talked
earlier in the uh in the podcast about
how those uh entitlements are going to
get cut sooner rather than later can you
um uh can you imagine can you visualize
the politics of that as we get closer to
those dates
so you want me to talk about
entitlements in the United States in
response to a question about whether or
not Liz trust was uh doing libertarian
stuff in the UK
uh the question is if you would have
listened to it or read it when I put it
on the slack channel is do Americans
have the stomach required to approach
such policies would you like me to read
again a third time would that would that
make it work yeah
and is wait is this from Larkin Hogle
Hogle Hogle oh yeah straight that guy
that guy is you know it's just hit after
hit for Larkin Hogle
so we'll let's let's start with the UK
because I think that's instructive the
the issue there was that she wasn't
doing libertarian policy stuff she was
she was running up the debt there was a
huge huge energy subsidy there and the
tax cuts that she uh that she proposed
were entirely debt financed that is not
the libertarian way of doing things and
this it is uh sometimes described as
libertarian but that's not correct you
can't like it the I understand like
Libertarians do sometimes have differing
opinions about this but I just like I
don't think that it is in any way fair
to characterize uh debt Finance tax cuts
so tax cuts without any offsetting
spending cuts and in fact with
effectively an offspending offsetting
spending increase in the form of a giant
energy subsidy
um that's not libertarian policy We
Can't Stop people from saying that it is
libertarian policy
um and in the United States we're gonna
face the same thing which is that people
are gonna say that any effort to reform
government programs that are on track to
fall apart on their own because of the
design that they already have
people will say oh that's that's a
that's a crazy libertarian idea to
reform those programs and try to make
them more fiscally stable
it's not a crazy like that's it's like
either of those programs are are going
to not be able to pay their bills or
they're going to be reformed one way or
the other now my suspicion is that
Republicans will not actually introduce
and pass and successfully pass sensible
reforms here like if you if you ask me
to bet up on how this is going to go in
the United States what's going to happen
is Republicans are going to propose
something that maybe has some good
elements and some dumb elements if we're
lucky uh and then it won't pass and then
what and then a couple of years from now
we will end up with Medicare
being months or you know weeks away from
not being able to pay all of its bills
and there will just be some sort of
temporary or ongoing temporary set of
measures that uh that sort of fund the
Gap there and Congress will will like
not it will not come to a resolution the
programs won't be reformed and they will
sort of hang in the balance of like well
you know every six months or so we have
to reauthorize our temporary solution
that we have passed initially saying
well we need six more months to come up
with a compromise that's what's going to
happen it's going to be dumb it's not
going to be productive but the idea that
that like reforming Social Security and
Medicare programs that are you know a
half century old or older that were
designed badly that were designed for a
completely different world
um and that we're going to do so in a
way that's like that actually plans you
know a couple of years out rather than
Waits until the very last minute if
that's your idea of like oh that's
that's you know some very scary
libertarian like doesn't that actually
sound like a better plan than just
waiting until those programs stop being
able to pay all their bills on their own
Fiona um uh you've been writing about
this and following this uh today Rishi
sunak the former treasury secretary how
can we get that fentanyl that you're
always writing about how can we get sick
to stop answering questions addressed to
a person named Fiona hey Fiona just
trying to not name welcome her um um so
the Rishi sunak was uh was uh appointed
uh prime minister uh today former
treasury secretary he's I think he's
richer than Midas I think is richer than
the Royals says The Drudge reports it
must be true
um I think the uh first uh first prime
minister of South Asian Heritage first
Hindu and maybe I'm not sure first a
Goldman Sachs uh uh alumnus uh I'm gonna
read to you an Associated Press you're
starting to sound like Kanye West I'm
going to read you I'm going to read to
you a uh a paragraph from the Associated
Press this is a news report
and this is similar to the uh the email
uh question
um his challenge is enormous as he tries
to unite it demoralized and divided
party that Trails far behind the
opposition in opinion polls and seeks to
shore up an economy reeling after
truss's brief disastrous experiment in
libertarian economics
uh uh is that inaccurate as far as you
can tell uh you know he's he's been
pretty vocal uh well at least previously
I think he kind of walked this back
since but previously he said that the
tax cuts were a fairy tale and he was
quoted as saying that borrowing your way
out of inflation isn't a plan which
seems to cut to Peter's point that
there's a lot of not libertarian-ness to
this uh but I think it's it's important
to mention you know people are people
going to call things libertarian is as
long as you know things are happening
but one independent analysis projected
that those tax cuts were going to cost
you know about 207 billion US dollars in
the fiscal year and my understanding is
that trust kind of skated this normal
budget analysis that's kind of customary
for these policies and I guess there was
this uh kind of inclination to act
quickly and decisively that very
severely backfired
um whether sunac is going to try
something similar it's hard to say you
know Liz truss had something like a 10
approval rating by the time she ended up
getting booted uh I guess everybody was
keeping an eye on that thing from The
Daily Mail whether she would outlive the
lettuce right that was slowly rotting in
a corner is there a final verdict on
that one the last one oh yeah the
lettuce is doing well it's not quite a
Big Mac right that would be something
else but you know it's hard to say that
he would do anything similar I'm not a
super close Watcher of British politics
but you would have to be insane to kind
of replicate that so quickly
Nick is there go ahead I do think if
we're talking about you know the and uh
the you know Larkin's question and I
feel like we're on a personal basis with
him by this point
um but is is about the Libertarians like
being slandered
um in America for many many years
Libertarians and I'm thinking of people
who either were libertarian explicitly
or traveled in uh adjacent circles like
Grover norquist always talked about how
any tax cut is good any tax cut is a win
and they never talked about cutting
spending uh in concert with tax cuts
that you know Grover norquist for most
of his career he's changed Tunes I like
him a lot he's great he's fantastic on
immigration in particular but for most
of his career he was not saying we need
to cut taxes and offset those with
spending cuts he actually believed like
a lot of deranged uh supply side people
that like you just cut taxes and the
economy will take care of itself and
government spending will be covered or
they would talk about cutting government
programs in totally separate ways but
but that's part of the problem here is
that Libertarians went along for a long
long time with just saying oh just cut
taxes just got taxes starve the Beast uh
or uh you know which is actually
something that William nescan in the
late uh head of uh the Cato Institute
talked about for a long time we bear
some responsibility for an association
between Libertarians and tax cuts that
are not paid for it's really only in the
past decade and I would point to uh
particularly work done by veronique
derushi who was at uh Cato at AEI and is
now at mercatus who really focused in on
the idea that debt Finance tax cuts are
disastrous in all sorts of ways and we
have a slightly different rhetoric about
that we also take it on the chin for
questions about austerity about cutting
spending particularly in difficult times
it's a good idea the real problem is not
that it has been tried and shown wanting
is that it's never been tried back in
the financial crisis uh you know people
are always talking about how England was
going through this austerity period they
never cut government spending even at
the time where everybody was saying oh
you know you're you're killing people
because of that something similar
happened in the U.S so Libertarians do I
think unless you know your libertarian
nihilist uh or an anarchist nihilist and
you just say just cut taxes cut taxes
cut taxes you know maximize the
contradictions amenitize the ashiton and
all of that you gotta talk like the way
Peter started this out with which is
that if you're cutting taxes you need to
cut spending otherwise really really bad
stuff I would point and we'll link it in
the in the post for this piece but we've
done a few uh interviews with Grover
norquist over the years just basically
arguing this in which he has said things
like you know uh my biggest worry is
that people are going to worry too much
about the size the deficit because in
his reading when people were uh worry
about the deficit that means taxes are
going to go up
um and you know those of us on the other
side of it have been arguing that you've
gotta actually cut government or else
what the hell are you even doing uh
Peter is there any other besides the tax
cut and spend uh take away from uh the
uh the what's happening in the UK is
there any other takeaway from uh from
the tumultuous events over there
England's becoming Italy it's just new
government every week and a half there
is there anything else that you find of
particular interest over there yeah so
the parliamentary system has
some good things and some bad things
about it there is they have the capacity
in the parliamentary system to do
something that doesn't happen in the
United States which is when a when the
Prime Minister goes off the rails
instead of the rest of the party
rallying around that prime minister and
deciding to support them the rest of the
party says hey wait you're bad for us
we're gonna get rid of you and that
doesn't happen in the United States
where if you have a president who is uh
who is clearly taking the party and the
country in a bad Direction what happens
in the United States is and this is for
True for Democrats and for Republicans
the rest of the party just sort of lines
up to defend whatever dumb stuff the
president is doing or wants to do and
that goes to policy decisions it goes to
Personnel decisions and it goes to
personality stuff
in particular with Joe Biden and
president Trump you know we've just seen
that the Democratic party it's not quite
that no one in the Democratic party will
ever criticize Joe Biden that's not true
and it's not that no one in the
Republican Party would ever criticize
Donald Trump in any way but for the most
part the party formally backs the
president even to its own detriment and
the parliamentary system allows allows a
major political party who has a prime
minister in place who has clearly lost
the faith and trust of the people and
has gone and like
has sort of has gone to somewhere uh
that is uh that is taking the party in
the country in a bad place the the
parliamentary system allows them to say
nope
you're fired very quickly in a way that
just doesn't happen in the United States
I would will make a prediction not about
the political outcome uh but pursuant to
this uh precise point that Peter's
making that if uh Republicans indeed
clobber the Democrats
um well we will see the exception to
Peter's rule beginning November 9th we
will hear a lot about how old and sleepy
and Meandering and ineffective Joe Biden
is from Democrats and from the media if
uh indeed they get their hats handed to
them and Rob Reiner's dreams of fascism
come true um because do you think Joe
Biden will run for president in 2024 do
I think he will run in 24.
um yeah I think if if do you think that
the criticism will be effective at
taking him out if when Dianne Feinstein
and Nancy Pelosi uh come at him with
guns blazing yeah
and again you should never make
predictions but I'm going to make it uh
if Republicans take both houses I I
predict he will not run I predict that
uh that I mean there's already just
majorities of democratic voters don't
want him to run that's that's usually a
bad sign and if you are if they're being
unsuccessful I think they'll it'll be a
a stampede of Pete bootage and whoever
the hell else we'll uh we'll come in and
Gavin Newsom versus Ron DeSantis I want
can you jump off I think it's I I think
you're I was gonna say Jared Leto uh
which would be a real wild card but uh I
think Jared Polis is going to make a uh
a big uh
to be the candidate of uh centuries um I
wish that I typically don't vote but I
would vote for Jared Leto just if you
could just like oh yeah run on uh it's
morbidden time platform yeah no if if he
did a steam campaign that would be great
but he could also be like he could be
the vice president if he's the character
from the Dallas Buyers Club oh so it's a
balanced ticket it's a man and a woman
let's go to our end of podcast what we
have been consuming in the cultural
Arena Fiona take us I've been so tired
of the True Crime and the political
stuff and sports documentaries I'm
reaching the end of the 30 for 30. so my
pick for this week is a perfect bid the
contestant Who Knew Too Much which is a
delightful uh somewhat old documentary
about a guy who was obsessed with the
Price Is Right uh he realized that there
was a pattern to the prizes that they
would show and he would memorize all of
the prizes and he would attend the
tapings he would drive to the tapings in
California and he would shout out the
answers to help people get the perfect
bid on the show and the central conflict
is this uh person who got the exact
right price for the final showcase and
he always said that he did it with no
assistance and there's this diverging
Narrative of whether he actually got
help and we hear from friend of Reason
Drew Carey and some old archive footage
and it's it's just a delightful
wonderful
somewhat thrilling Saga I found myself
really really liking it and it's a it's
a good cleanse from the whole wide world
so highly recommend
that sounds terrific but then he got
sentenced by one of those weird
California judges met you know who make
people uh you know have a punishment
that is somehow demeaning so the guy was
spayed and neutered by uh
tragic expected turn
uh Nick what did you consume besides
drugs this morning I am uh yeah I uh I
am reading uh Burning Down The House how
libertarian philosophy was corrupted by
uh
uh X and Y what do you think it is
Burning Down The House by how
libertarian philosophy was corrupted by
blank
[Laughter]
racism
and uh uh
and
Nazis
okay no anyone want to try how
libertarian philosophy I feel like we're
on uh Match Game
uh you know little Susie said that
libertarian philosophy was corrupted by
blank and blank
uh rainbow fentanyl
no it was regular fentanyl it was
actually it was no it was how
libertarian philosophy was corrupted by
delusion and greed yeah greed Burning
Down The House how libertarian
philosophy was corrupted by delusion and
greed uh it's written by Andrew
koppelman it has a blurb from a long
time risen contributor uh Deirdre
McCloskey
um and it is a an interesting attack
that is
um like all such things is ultimately
has bad faith behind it but it's a very
good read Because on the cover which is
one of the it's it's published by uh
Saint Martins but it has a cover that
would make the Cato the eagle
the the bald eagle that appears on every
cover of every Cato book cry
um because it's so bad Capital rotunda
of oh that would be really nice yeah or
Uncle Sam it has like a belt that's
tightening on him while he's playing
chess with jigsaw puzzle pieces of
countries from the Middle East
uh no it's Friedrich Hayek in the outlet
of a house
with flames coming out of it it is so
hilariously awful to cover but uh it's a
good book it's an important book because
it is a massive critique of libertarian
thinking and basically the guy is
arguing that Hayek who should you know
is really the the heart and soul of
libertarianism uh has been hijacked by
people particularly Rand rothbard and
nozick or follower of these people who
have taken libertarianism which is a
species of Classical liberalism which is
a species of you know kind of a you know
a liberal philosophy that includes
conservatives as well as liberals and
Libertarians are somewhere in the middle
and taken to the outer uh outer reaches
of anarchism why it's bad faith is that
he also hates Hayek and that's kind of
bad it's like oh you know if only
Libertarians were more like Hayek that
would be great except that I kind of
hate Hayek but having said that it is a
serious critique
um and it is one that I find extremely
um you know uh compelling and engaging
and it is something that I think the
libertarian movement is at a Crossroads
uh you know and we're seeing this in the
way that the lp is going uh I think we
see it even in Generations at reason uh
younger people tend to be more
explicitly either rothbardian uh you
know explicitly or implicitly and move
towards anarchism as opposed to
liberalism uh it's a good book Burning
Down The House Andrew koplinize Peter
what have you been consuming
I watched the season finale of House of
the Dragon on HBO it is the prequel to
Game of Thrones and over the course of
10 episodes in the first season it
mostly won me over like Game of Thrones
uh it's a show about a power vacuum uh
about the patriarchy and political
violence
um and it is it's really effectively
done in a lot of ways uh in particular
given the risks that it took this show
replaced the cast like three times
throughout the season so many of the
main characters show up as multiple
different actors and that allows the
show to sort of hop through through big
moments in time I think in some ways
that is also the weakest thing about the
show like I said it mostly won me over
because it just focuses on the really
big moments uh you know sort of turning
points in this story of A A house
divided against itself in a you know
sort of medieval fantasy setting um
in a weird way it reminded me of that
movie based on a play Closer which had
like Clive Owen and Natalie Portman in
it and a couple other uh famous uh folks
it was a quartet of famous actors
actresses and every scene in the movie
was a scene of either breaking up or
getting together right there was no in
between in the relationships it was
always like let's just gut to the chase
at every point and House of the Dragon
operates somewhat similarly in that
every single episode is something really
big happens there are big portentous
moments uh in particular this the finale
here of course ends on a very big turn
your sort of turning point in what is uh
promises to be a major war throughout
the um throughout the land but it's a
good show a good
um a very effective kind of late Peak
television you know experiments in late
Peak television because they've realized
at this point that they have to outdo
themselves every single episode until
every single episode uh delivers some
sort of Mega spectacle of the kind that
you just couldn't find on television
even 15 years ago or so and so in that
way it's very impressive I do hope that
the second season slows down just a
little bit and gives us some of those
smaller character moments that are
missing from this season so my uh
consumption is uh an article a long
magazine article that I haven't even yet
finished but it's so delightful uh at
the uh at the top half of it
um that I can tell it's going to be just
one of the best things that is it a
William langave but it is Paceman is it
the one about the Treaty of the seasons
my name's not Fiona 911 uh so it's in
the Atlantic so it's it's language in
that sense uh it's uh uh called the uh
original tiger Kings the improbable rise
and Savage fall of
come on Nick Siegfried and Roy
that's right that is absolutely right uh
it's great I've been thinking a lot
lately for uh whatever reason about the
kind of transmission of cultural
knowledge and uh history and such and
that brought you to a book length expose
a depiction of a moment in time of
American culture of Las Vegas Arnold
Schwarzenegger plays a starring role as
he always does especially when he's in
the supporting role
um uh it's just like crazy wonderful and
very very well done uh writing um it's
uh it's a model for uh long-form
magazine what's the uh what's the point
what like I mean what is the moment um I
mean it's just it's a it's a you're
gonna get to it at the end where there's
going to be a horrible mauling um but
it's just uh the rise of of uh why why
in the world were there two weird
sculpted German magicians with a bunch
of wild cats in uh uh gigantic uh Las
Vegas hotel on top of the world it's uh
it's such a random bit of of uh of
modern cultural history and it's
wonderful to read about and you learn
about you learn about yourself Nick
um uh in it uh we're all Siegfried and
Roy in some way uh but no did you relate
or Roy or the Tiger uh they're actually
their assistant
um who uh
I think I would have liked them more if
their official name was Siegfried or Roy
because that's a real challenge it's
about choice not control or Dostoyevsky
uh anyways uh terrific piece who wrote
it who wrote it is this like originally
from like you know the 19th century
Atlantic is it like William Jennifer and
I was supposed to put that I have to cut
and paste and and uh oh sure here Chris
you haven't even done this and Michael J
Mooney I don't know why you need a J in
your Mooney Michael and Larkin Hogle was
the arthur to try to distinguish
yourself from all the other Michael
Mooney's out there
um
he's a moody running down the holler
isn't there a famous like uh Kentucky
drinking song about Mooney
running from revenues language you're
speaking uh anyway great article go
check it out the original tiger kings in
the Atlantic uh this is all the uh Nick
interruptions that we have time for in
one podcast no I think we got time for
one more three uh if you uh like what we
do
um at reason go to reason.com donate
give us money uh we have lots of other
podcasts go to recent.com podcast find
out all about it Nick do you have any
upcomings you want to uh advertise here
oh yeah Zach wise Miller for uh
Wednesday's recent interview with Nick
Gillespie uh is actually by Zach
Weissmuller and uh he talks to uh
embattled controversial Philadelphia
Larry krasner that's exciting it's it's
this one is pure fire that's nice Zach
weissmull a great American a great
American grateful it really is yeah
despite a name that you know is very
suspicious to be quite honest pure fire
just like the cover to that Burning Down
The House book
yes well that's false fire I think
that's a lot of smoke
but not so much
Zach wise Miller brings the heat okay
I'm gonna say stop now so that we stop
podcast he brings the fentanyl like a
Chinese illegal immigrant coming in
through a legal Port of Entry so one of
those documented by Fiona Harrigan one
of the recommended articles alongside of
that secrete and Roy piece in the
Atlantic is how to end a conversation
without making up an excuse goodbye
maybe you should read that one Matt
goodbye
[Music]
I've seen you try
[Music]